Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Ein Skandal ungeahnten Ausmaßes erschüttert den belgischen Fußball, Hausdurchsuchungen, Verhaftungen, alles mit dabei. Worum geht's? Das erklärt uns jetzt Boris Cremer, Belgien-Korrespondent vom Kicker. Boris, schön, dass du so spontan Zeit gefunden hast für dein Rasenfunk-Debüt, hallo. Ja, trotzdem sehr nett von dir. Heute Morgen hätte ich noch nicht gedacht, dass ich etwas über den belgischen Fußball machen wollen würde. Und wenige Stunden später stehe ich da, bekomme deinen Kontakt und wir führen ein kurzes Telefonat, in dem wir feststellen, okay, das müssen wir jetzt quasi aufzeichnen. Es ist heute eine Art sportpolitische Bombe geplatzt. Kannst du uns mal die ganz einfache Frage beantworten? Was ist denn eigentlich passiert?
Ja, das ist eine einfache Frage mit einer nicht ganz einfachen Antwort. Denn fest steht nur, dass heute eine wirklich beispiellose Welle von Haussuchsuchungen, wie du auch schon im Teaser gesagt hast, von Ratschen, von Verhören stattgefunden hat, die sich im Kern, muss man sagen, um zwei Spieler Makler, um zwei Spieler Vermittler dreht, um Moghi Bajad und Dejan Belkovic. Die große Frage ist eigentlich nur, was alles noch da dranhängt. Denn unter anderem geht es auch um Schiedsrichter, die festgenommen wurden. Es geht um Vereine, deren Geschäftsräume durchsucht worden sind. Und laut der Staatsanwaltschaft gibt es Verdachtsmomente, die eigentlich nicht direkt was miteinander zu tun haben. Es geht nämlich zum einen um die Frage, ob organisierte Kriminalität im Zusammenhang mit Transfers, mit Steuerhinterziehung im Spiel war. Und zum anderen um Spielmanipulation. Und da ist jetzt die Frage, man könnte sich jetzt einen Reim drauf machen. Da haben zwei Spielervermittler die eine oder andere Million am Fiskus vorbei geschleust. Das kommt ja nicht zum ersten Mal vor. Aber zum anderen geht es eben darum, dass dieser Verdacht der privaten Korruption, heißt es dann von offizieller Seite, sprich Spielmanipulation, irgendwo besteht. Und da ist jetzt die große Frage, wie hängt das zusammen?
Ja, und das, was es eben so beeindruckt macht, sind wirklich eigentlich in dem Fall auch die Zahlen. Du hast die beiden Hauptverdächtigen schon genannt. Insgesamt waren 184 belgische Beamte und 36 ausländische Beamte. Das heißt, 220 polizeilich ermittelnde Beamte waren da involviert. Und trotzdem ist zumindest meines Wissens nach nichts nach außen gedrungen. Hat dich das auch überrascht, dass das heute Morgen alles stattgefunden hat?
Also selbst, sag ich mal, die gewissesten Journalisten des Landes waren perplex. Es hat keinerlei Vorboten gegeben in den letzten Wochen, dass es vielleicht geheißen hätte, da ist was im Busch. Also das war wirklich eine für alle sehr überraschende Aktion, muss man sagen.
Und dann insgesamt 44 Hausdurchsuchungen, unter anderem zehn Erstligaclubs waren da auch mit dabei, unter anderem RSC Anderlecht, Standard Lüttich, Royal Antwerpen und der Club Brügge, bei dem auch der Trainer ein bisschen flüten gegangen ist. Denn der ist jetzt erst mal, wie ich es richtig verstanden habe, in Untersuchungshaft.
Ja, also das ist natürlich ein Hammer, muss man sagen. Also der Meister-Trainer Ivan Lenko wird festgenommen im Zuge einer solchen Affäre. Also das ist wirklich beispiellos. Bei den anderen Vereinen muss man eigentlich sagen, geht man im Moment davon aus, dass wirklich nur durchsucht wurde, dass man auf der Suche war nach Vertragspapieren, nach irgendwas Schriftlichem, was Aufschluss geben könnte über diese erwähnten Steuerhinterziehungen, die mutmaßlichen. Aber was bei Ivan Lenko jetzt da los ist, das sprengt wirklich alle Maßstäbe, muss man sagen. Also er hätte heute zum Training erscheinen sollen, ist er dann natürlich nicht, weil er eben von der Polizei heute Morgen an seinem Domizil festgenommen wurde. Die Spur führt da zu dem Gesagten Dejan Veljkovic. Die beiden sind wohl gute Freunde, da hat Ivan Lenko nie einen Hehl daraus gemacht. Also der Spielerberater? Genau, Spielerberater Veljkovic, Trainer, Leko. Die kennen sich aus vergangenen Zeiten, als Leko Trainer in Lokeren war. Auch in Lokeren, Klammer auf Klammer zu, ist heute durchsucht worden. Also da führt die Spur hin. Und die Frage ist einfach nur jetzt, haben auch diese Lekotransfers seine eigenen sozusagen mit der ganzen Affäre zu tun? Hat er möglicherweise krumme Transfers eingefädelt, begünstigt? Ich denke, das sind jetzt so die Fragen, da hätte gerne die Justiz von Ivan Lenko ein paar Antworten.
Jetzt ist das in Deutschland so, wenn man in Untersuchungshaft genommen wird, dann gibt es schon einen sehr konkreten Tatverdacht, denn das muss ja ein Richter frei geben. Deckt sich das auch mit dem belgischen Rechtssystem? Also können wir davon ausgehen, es gibt einen begründeten Anfangsverdacht, dass man ihn eben direkt in Untersuchungshaft nimmt?
Ja, also den Anfangsverdacht muss es geben. Es ist allerdings so, dass man auch dann der Jury jetzt erst mal von einer Festnahme spricht und nicht von einer Verhaftung. Also da wird jetzt irgendwann ein Untersuchungsrichter entscheiden müssen, kommt er wirklich in Untersuchungshaft oder ist er jetzt erst mal nur in Gewahrheit. Also erst mal ist er in Polizeigewahrheit, müsste man jetzt eigentlich sagen. Aber das ist dann eher was für die Juristen unter uns. Ich weiß nicht, ob viele zuhören bei dir, aber...
Doch, ja, durchaus. Es gilt natürlich auch die Unschuldsvermutung, aber es ist schon ein beispielloser Schritt, da einen Erstligatrainer, der unter anderem ja auch Champions League-Gegner von Borussia Dortmund ist, festzunehmen. Auch deswegen gibt es vielleicht noch mal ein besonderes Interesse jetzt an dieser Personalie. Es geht um Steuerbetrug, um Geldwäsche und auch um Spielmanipulation. Du hast schon gesagt, das sind ja so drei Dinge, die ursächlich gar nicht miteinander zusammenhängen. Ich habe jetzt gelesen unter anderem, dass der Ausgangspunkt für den Vorwurf der Spielmanipulation wohl eine Klage das VC Westerloh gewesen sein soll, der am letzten Spieltag 2016, 2017 abgestiegen ist. Da angemahnt hat, da wäre es wohl bei einem Konkurrenten alles nicht mit richtigen Dingen zugegangen.
Ja, das ist korrekt. Da geht es um den letzten Spieltag der Saison 2016, 2017. Damals hat Macron, die eigentlich dem Abstieg geweiht waren, völlig überraschend auswärts in Kortrijk eigentlich eine gute Mannschaft 2-0 gewonnen. Deshalb musste Vesolo absteigen und das hat wirklich damals für Furore gesorgt. Also Kortrijk hat da wirklich mit völlig gebremstem Schaum gespielt, also fast aufreizend sich sozusagen dann der Niederlage hingegeben. Und damals ist schon wild spekuliert worden. Ja, war das jetzt Wettbewerbsverzerrung nur in Anführungszeichen oder war es wirklich schon eine Spielmanipulation? Also Wettbewerbsverzerrung war es in jedem Fall. Also Kortrijk hatte überhaupt nichts mehr dran getan. Aber da hat schon wirklich die wildesten Spekulationen gegeben. Hinzu kommt, dass Mukron, um die es ja damals ging, in der vergangenen Saison so eine ähnliche Geschichte hatte, diesmal waren sie aber nicht sozusagen als Abschiebskandidat beteiligt, beziehungsweise sie waren schon abgestiegen. Von daher ist es immer wieder der Verein, der dann letzten Endes in diese Schlagzeilen gerät. Und das ist offensichtlich Teil dieser Untersuchung. Man geht davon aus, dass dieses besagte Spiel, Kochtrag gegen Mukron, damals so ein bisschen den Stein ins Rollen gebracht hat. Aber der eigentliche Strippenzieher, als der gilt ja dieser Moghi Bayat, muss man sagen. Und da führt auch jetzt so ein bisschen die Spur hin zu diesen Spielmanipulationen, weil Moghi Bayat, muss man wissen, ist ein ganz windiger Geschäftsmann und der scheint auch kein Kind von Traurigkeit zu sein. Und der muss wohl auch schon mal so hinter vorgehaltener Hand Vereinen gedroht haben. So im Sinne von, wenn ihr den Transfer jetzt taten lasst, dann werdet ihr mal sehen, wer am Ende der Saison absteigt und wer nicht. Und deshalb vermutet jetzt der eine oder andere, dass er hier und da mal ernst gemacht hat. Dass er vielleicht nicht unbedingt gezielt einzelne Spiele manipuliert hat, aber dass er schon in irgendeiner Form Einfluss genommen hat auf den Ausgang einer ganzen Saison.
Ja, das sind natürlich schon sehr deutliche Aussagen, wenn sie denn so gefallen sind. Und ich habe jetzt überall, wo ich etwas lesen konnte über Moghi, bei Jad, immer die Formulierung gelesen, er ist der einflussreichste Spielervermittler in Belgien. Also kein unbeschriebenes und kein unbedeutendes Blatt.
Nee, alles andere als das. Und vor allem, er hat das innerhalb von ein paar Jahren, hat er diese Reputation aufgebaut, ob es jetzt positiv oder negativ ist. Lassen wir jetzt mal so dahingestellt, aber Tatsache ist, dass inzwischen, muss man sagen, kein Top-Transfer innerhalb Belgiens zumindest ohne Moghi Bayat läuft. Er ist zum Beispiel unter anderem auch Manager von Heim van Hasenbroek, dem Trainer des RSC Anderlecht. Und er hat allein im Sommer eine ganze Reihe von Transfers ins Ausland eingefädelt. Und es heißt immer, wenn irgendwie so ein Transfer so auf der Kippe steht, dann holt sich irgendeine Partei Moghi Bayat dazu. Und dann wird das Ding innerhalb von ein paar Stunden geritzt. Und er hat so ein bisschen jetzt den Ruf sich erarbeitet, vor allem auch bei Spielern, dass er eben die Dinger zuschnürt. Und ja, so kommt es eben, dass auch die Vereine auf ihn angewiesen sind. Ich meine, das kennst du ja auch so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich. Das ist eben dieses übliche Spiel. Die Vereine sind auf die Transfers angewiesen. Also sind sie dann in letzter Instanz auch irgendwo hängsam tropf von diesen Spielermaklern. Und er spielt das dann sehr gekonnt aus und macht sich unverzichtbar. Also man sagt, er hat eigentlich bei jedem Verein in Belgien einen Fuß in der Tür. Und jeder weiß, ohne ihn geht es einfach nicht. Und diese Position der Stärke, die spielt er dann wirklich, muss man sagen, aus. Zum Teil anscheinend mit recht zweifelhaften Methoden. Also er setzt da wirklich Spieler und Vereine auch teilweise massiv unter Druck. Er ist ein Rüpel gegenüber Journalisten. Also da laufen auch teilweise Klagen vom belgischen Sportjournalistenverband, weil er auch da Druck ausübt auf Medienvertreter. Also das ist wirklich, muss man sagen, kein Kind von Traurigkeit.
Ja, unglaublich. Und das alles binnen weniger Jahre. Und dann scheint er sehr, sehr viel Macht innerhalb der Liga aufgebaut zu haben. Jetzt, wenn ich mich an vergleichbare Fälle, also schwierig jetzt direkt eins zu eins zu vergleichen, aber an andere solche Untersuchungen im Fußballumfeld erinnere, dann gab es da dann meistens am Tag der Hausdurchsuchung und der ersten Ingewahrsamnehmung von Verdächtigen. Da gab es dann auch immer Pressekonferenzen. Sehe ich das richtig, dass sich aber die belgische Staatsanwaltschaft da jetzt noch gar nicht geäußert hat?
Ja, das ist korrekt. Also die Informationen waren sehr spärlich. Also man hat darüber kommuniziert, bei welchen Vereinen durchsucht wurde. Man hat, wie gesagt, diese einzelnen Verdachtsmomente grob geschildert. Also organisierte Kriminalität, Geldwäsche und Spielmanipulation. Aber man ist nicht weit in die Details gegangen. Also man hat jetzt beispielsweise nicht gesagt, warum man den einen oder den anderen festgenommen hat. Das, muss man sagen, hat dann natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Spekulation angehalten. Bisher hat es da keine präzise Information gegeben, was wohl interessant ist. Das hat die Staatsanwaltschaft heute Abend mitgeteilt, dass jeder der Festgenommenen ein Verdächtiger ist. Weil es hatte zuerst geheißen, ja, die gelten vielleicht in der ganzen Affäre als mögliche Zeugen oder Kronzeugen oder was auch immer. Nein, sie haben gesagt, selbst ein Hermann Van Holtzpick beispielsweise, der bis zum Frühjahr und während 15 Jahren Manager des RSV Anderlecht war, selbst der gilt also als Verdächtiger in dieser ganzen Affäre und zwei Schiedsrichter, Bart Verzenten und Sebastien Delferriere, die auf Top-Niveau Schiedsrichtern, selbst die gelten also demnach als Verdächtige.
Zwei FIFA-Schiedsrichter zählen eben auch zu denjenigen, die jetzt erstmal in Gewahrsam genommen wurden und wie du jetzt dann eben sagst als Verdächtige zählen. Das zeigt die ganze Dimension, das ganze Ausmaß davon. Jetzt aus den spärlichen Informationen, die man hat. Es gibt zum einen den Hinweis darauf, dass eben der VZ Westerloh sich beklagt hat am letzten Spieltag 2016, 2017. Aus den anderen Meldungen, die man so lesen kann, heißt es, dass Ende 2017 die Abteilung Sportbetrug der Bundespolizei Hinweise auf verdächtige Transaktionen in der Liga erhalten hat. Daraus würde ich jetzt aus der Entfernung eins und eins zusammenzählen und würde sagen, es gab diesen Verdacht auf Spielmanipulation, da konnte man nichts nachweisen, aber als man da verdächtige finanzielle Transaktionen bemerkt hat, konnte man unter anderem eine Querverbindung herstellen. Ist das arg spekulativ?
Ja, also bei den besagten Finanztransaktionen, die da aufgetaucht sind, da ging es wohl eher um Transfergelder. Also da ging es eher um die Frage der Steuerinterziehung, also man vermutet, dass es eher in diese Kategorie fällt, aber Tatsache ist auch angesichts dieser konzertierten Aktion des heutigen Tages, dass es da Zusammenhänge geben muss, das heißt, irgendwo muss es irgendwo einen roten Faden geben und es scheint irgendwo offensichtlich, dass Spielmanipulationen zumindest Teil dieser Machenschaft waren, aber welche Rolle sie genau gespielt haben, ist nicht so ganz klar. Es scheint nicht so klassisch irgendwas zu tun zu haben mit einer Wettmafia, das hat man in der Vergangenheit zum Beispiel auch in Belgien leidvoll erfahren müssen. Es scheint hier in dem Falle, wenn man so ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen liest, die Spielmanipulation irgendwo nur Teil von einer höheren Aktion gewesen zu sein, die aber andere Ziele verfolge. So hat es zumindest den Anschein im Moment.
Belgiens Justizminister hat dazu auch getwittert, wie man das heutzutage macht, und hat geschrieben, Spielmanipulationen untergraben die Integrität des Sports. Das ist alles sehr, sehr vage, finde ich. Auch, dass noch keine Volumina genannt werden. Wenn wir da über Steuerbetrug und Geldwäsche reden, da wissen wir ja leidvoll aus Erfahrung. Da geht es ja im Fußball schnell in die Millionenbeträge.
Ja, also da kann man wirklich auch tatsächlich nur spekulieren. Man geht davon aus, dass Moghi Bayat in den letzten Jahren Transfer- Provisionserlöse von knapp 10 Millionen Euro erzielt hat. Ich sage mal, sein Kollege, da dürfte sich das in einem ähnlichen Rahmen bewegen, vielleicht etwas weniger. Das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwo die, das werden die Summen sein, die da im Spiel sind. Aber gut, in der Tat, also es hat noch keine irgendwelche Beträge genannt. Bei den Spielmanipulationen, wie gesagt, da ist in meinen Augen die Frage, ob da überhaupt Geld das entscheidende Element war oder ob es eher darum ging, Druck und Macht auszuüben. Das scheint eher der Fall gewesen zu sein, weil wie gesagt, man hat nicht irgendwelche verdächtigen Wetteinsätze registriert. Das war in der Vergangenheit oft so, dann hieß es plötzlich, hey, da wurden plötzlich irgendwie 500.000 Euro auf ein belgisches Zweitligaspiel gesetzt. Schaut mal genauer hin. Das hat man jetzt im Zusammenhang mit der Affäre von heute nicht gehört. Sprich, es liegt der Verdacht nahe, dass, wie gesagt, das eigentlich nur Mittel zum Zweck war. Könnte man aber nur spekulieren, wie gesagt, also genaueres weiß man nicht.
Es ist ja auch immer die Frage, mit welchem Ziel man manipuliert. Das eine Ziel kann sein, Wettgewinne zu erzielen, das andere Ziel kann natürlich ein sportliches Ergebnis sein, wie eben zum Beispiel, dass man nicht absteigt oder jemand anderes nicht absteigt dafür. Wenn du jetzt schon davon sprichst, dass man da in der Vergangenheit schon Erfahrungen gemacht hat, wie reiht sich denn dieser Skandal jetzt ein in die belgische Fußballgeschichte? Ich meine, in Deutschland kennen wir den Bundesligaskandal, der liegt jetzt schon viele Jahrzehnte zurück. Dann gab es mal eine Enthüllung oder Veröffentlichung von Declan Hill, wo angeblich auch Zweitligaspiele betroffen wären. Spielmanipulation findet aber in der Bundesliga, in der öffentlichen Diskussion kaum statt, womit ich nicht sagen will, dass es völlig ausgeschlossen ist, dass es hier etwas gäbe. Aber wie ist denn da der Stand in Belgien?
In der Hinsicht muss man sagen, ist Belgien ein gebranntes Kind. Es hat in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten immer wieder Mutmaßungen und zum Teil muss man sagen auch richtige Beweise gegeben. Es hat einige Affären gegeben, die wohl die Älteren unter uns, werden sich daran erinnern, eindrucksvollste. Das war die sogenannte Standart-Water-Scheiaffäre. Da ging es im Wesentlichen um Standart Lüttich. Die haben gegen die gegnerischen Mannschaften wirklich bestochen, um 1982 Belgischer Meister zu werden. Damals war unter anderem und später dann gesperrt worden Remo Guthals, der Trainer von Standart Lüttich involviert, der später Erfolge mit Olympique Marseille gefeiert hat, Champions League-Sieger geworden ist, mit Marseille und Rudi Völler. Der ist also damals gesperrt worden, unter anderem. Aber eine ganze Reihe von anderen waren da involviert, auch an Michel Predom beispielsweise, Eric Gerrits, den kennt man ja auch in Deutschland. Die sind alle damals für mehrere Jahre gesperrt worden. Also das war so diese in den 80er Jahren die wirklich eindrucksvollste Affäre im Zusammenhang mit Bestechungen, mit Spielmanipulationen. Und die nächste Welle, die ist vor gut zehn Jahren gerollt, da gab es die Affäre Seyounier, da ging es um einen chinesischen Geschäftsmann namens Seyounier und einen Spielerberater Pietro Allatta aus Italien, die wirklich gezielt auf Vereine infiltriert haben, um dann an Spieler zu kommen, die offensichtlich zu haben waren für solche krummen Dinger. Die haben beispielsweise den damaligen Trainer des Leerste SK in der ersten belgischen Liga Paul Püt als Kompliz gewinnen können. Der hat dann offensichtlich einige seiner Spieler mit ins Boot geholt, die haben absichtlich verloren. Er selber hat teilweise einfach sozusagen die B-Mannschaft aufgestellt damals. Gleichzeitig wurde in Fernost fleißig auf Niederlagen des Leerste SK gesetzt. Und da sind wirklich damals Leute, also dieser Paul Püt, wie gesagt, aber auch Seunier selber, zu mehrjährigen Gefängnisstrafen verurteilt worden. Und das war übrigens die Zeit, da kam wenig später dieser Calciopoli-Skandal in Italien zum Vorschein. Nach einem ähnlichen Muster, bzw. ging es eben auch um Spiele und Manipulation im großen Spiel. Juventus damals gesperrt worden, bzw. zwangsabgestiegen. Das war eben so diese Welle damals, das hat in ganz Europa damals so für Furore gesorgt. Seitdem muss man sagen, ist Belgien auch immer im Verdacht, da irgendwo Spielwiese bzw. Instrument zu sein für solche größeren mafiösen Strukturen. Das liegt auch einfach daran, dass eben in Belgien noch nicht das ganz große Geld rollt im Fußball. Das heißt, gerade in den unteren Ligen sind Spieler, aber auch Schiedsrichter beispielsweise empfänglicher für solche Bestechungsgelder. Man hat aber eigentlich ein bisschen daraus gelernt, es gibt Frühwarnsysteme inzwischen. Es ist gar nicht mehr so einfach, größere Geldbeträge auf recht unbedeutende belgische Fußballspiele zu setzen. Insofern ist es eigentlich die letzten Jahre in der Hinsicht ruhiger geworden, umso schockierender, dass dann heute eben dieser offensichtliche Skandal, von dem wir einfach mal jetzt ausgehen müssen, zum Vorschein gekommen ist.
Wie hat sich denn die Liga da bisher zu geäußert und wird es jetzt einfach ganz normal weitergehen?
Ja, also die Liga hat sich, wie viele andere auch, erstaunt gezeigt, aber gleichzeitig einräumen müssen, nicht wirklich informiert zu sein. Also offensichtlich hatten die jetzt auch nicht da irgendwelche Vorwarnungen bekommen, dass da was kommen würde. Der Geschäftsführer der Profi-Liga hat sich zu Wort gemeldet und Pierre-Francois und hat einfach nur gesagt, in jedem Falle ist es erstmal image-schädigend für den belgischen Fußball. Egal, was jetzt genau dahinter steckt.
Na, da hat er sich ja weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, was?
Ja, er weiß selber nicht genau, offensichtlich, was da jetzt vorliegt. Es ist auch bisher noch nicht gesagt worden, beziehungsweise man weiß nicht, ob jetzt irgendwo Spieltage verschoben werden sollen. Das hat man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt zumindest offensichtlich noch nicht ins Auge gefasst. Sebastian Delferriere, den hat sich ja eben angesprochen, den FIFA-Schiedsrichter, der ist jetzt schon mal vom Nations League-Spiel Georgien gegen, ich glaube, Andorra abgezogen worden. Hätte eigentlich pfeifen sollen am nächsten Samstag, daraus wird jetzt nichts, kann man sicher denken. Und ich sag mal, wenn man jetzt so die möglichen Mittel bis langfristigen Folgen ja absehen müsste, dann hängt natürlich sehr vieles davon ab, wie tief jetzt Leute verstrickt sind, wie Ivan Lenko, der Meister-Trainer, wie ein Hermann Van Holtzbeek, der aber die letzten 15 Jahre eigentlich den RSC Anderlecht sozusagen geführt hat, wie solche Leute und natürlich die beiden besagten Schiedsrichter, wie stark die irgendwo mit da drin hängen. Wenn es jetzt nur eine Geschichte ist von zwei Spielermaklern, die irgendwo, wie gesagt, Steuern hinterzogen haben und vielleicht irgendwo noch ein paar andere illegale Machenschaften am Laufen hatten, dann möchte ich nicht sagen, dass es da eine Bagatelle ist, weiß Gott nicht, aber dann hätte es glaube ich nicht so diese Schockwirkung, als wenn jetzt wirklich, sag ich mal, wirklich unbeschriebene Blätter oder unbescholtene Akteure, wie ein Trainer, wie Schiedsrichter, ich meine, das sind ja eigentlich sozusagen, die müssten ja die Hintegas überhaupt sein im ganzen Spiel, dass die dann plötzlich da drin auftauchen, also das könnte wirklich ganz schlimme Folgen haben und dann ist auch nicht so ganz abzusehen, wie es dann weitergeht, muss man sagen.
Also Sebastian Delphier hat auf FIFA-Niveau gepfiffen, hat 14 Europa-League-Spiele zum Beispiel gepfiffen, einmal Champions League-Qualifikation, Bartford Thornton, war jetzt noch nicht so viel international im Einsatz, aber das sind eben schon Schiedsrichter mit einem gewissen Namen, wo das besonders, ja.
Ja, so vertent ist es, ist in Belgien zumindest auf nationalem Niveau gilt, eben auch aufgrund seines Alters ein bisschen als einer der Shooting-Stars unter den Schiedsrichtern, also der gilt seit Jahren als einer der besten belgischen Schiedsrichter und dann kann man irgendwo einfach nur mit dem Kopf schütteln und sich die Frage stellen, was geht hier eigentlich vor? Also das ist einfach die große Frage, muss man sagen.
Jetzt hast du ja schon mal gesagt, dass die Belgische Liga vielleicht auch deswegen besonders anfällig für solche Machenschaften wäre, weil eben da nicht das große Geld zu verdienen ist und logischerweise sind dann Spieler empfänglicher für große Geldbeträge, die sie dann über irgendwelche krummen Dinge verdienen können. Wenn du jetzt aber sagst, dass es solche Fälle schon in den 80ern gab und jetzt dann auch eben Anfang der 2000er oder in diesem Zeitraum, warum schafft es die Liga nicht, sich dagegen zu schützen?
Ja, eine Erklärung dafür könnte sein, dass der belgische Fußball, ich sag mal strukturell betrachtet, sehr liberal ist. Er lässt zum Beispiel hundertprozentige Vereinsübernahmen zu, er lässt im Grunde genommen, muss man sagen, lässt er zu, dass sich ausländische Investoren quasi ohne irgendwelche größeren Hürden in Vereine irgendwo einstecken können und mit ihnen im Schlepptau dann oft so, ich sag mal, schräge Geschäftsmodelle, also oft kommen dann Investoren zu einem Zweitligaklub und haben direkt irgendwie fünf, sechs Spieler im Schlepptau, von denen man nicht genau weiß, wo kommen die jetzt genau her. Was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass es manchmal so ein bisschen einfach an Regularien fehlt, möglicherweise. Das Ganze ist oft ein bisschen undurchsichtig, auch die Investoren, um die es dann geht, vor allem beispielsweise auch in der zweiten belgischen Liga, das sind oft Leute, von denen man gar nicht genau weiß, was haben die hier eigentlich vor, wer steckt da im Hintergrund, gibt es da irgendwelche Strohmänner. Das ist alles immer sehr windig in Belgien und das birgt eben die Gefahr, dass irgendwo solche Machenschaften gar nicht richtig zum Vorschein kommen oder möglicherweise irgendwo nicht früh genug registriert werden. Der belgische Fußball hat eine gewisse Anfälligkeit einfach, muss man offen zugestehen.
Hat das Auswirkungen auf dessen Popularität bei den Fans, wie war das bei den vergangenen Fällen, wo so Manipulationen offenkundig wurden?
Nee, das hat in der Hinsicht keine negativen Auswirkungen. Es war letztendlich kein Verein verurteilt worden. Selbst der letzte SK, wo der Trainer absichtlich die B-Mannschaft hat spielen lassen, um zu verlieren, selbst dem hat man nicht nachweisen können, dass er als Verein auf dem Laufenden war. Es gab keinen Zwangsabstieg, z.B. Juventus Turin, und es hat somit der Eindruck entstanden, ok, da ging es um ein paar Kriminelle, die aber als Einzelfälle deklariert wurden. Man hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass Fans hinter das Licht geführt wurden, von einem kaputten Ligasystem oder von kaputten Funktionären. In der Hinsicht hat es keinen Imageschaden, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Das könnte in dem Fall durchaus der Fall sein. Denn hier steht die Reputation von Schlüsselfiguren im Belgischen Fußball auf dem Spiel. Also wie gesagt, ein Trainer Ivan Lenko, ein Manager oder zwei Schiedsrichter. Also das sind, wie gesagt, Leute, wo die Menschen da draußen wirklich nicht erwarten, dass sie jetzt irgendwo da mitmischen. Und da sehe ich dann tatsächlich einen Unterschied.
Hat sich die UEFA schon geäußert? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass im schlimmstmöglichen Fall belgischer Fußball international nicht unbedingt im nächsten Jahr stattfinden muss. Das könnte ja eine Maßnahme sein, gerade weil die UEFA sich selbst natürlich auch Transparenz und Integrität und all diese schönen, schönen Begriffe auf die Fahnen schreibt.
Ja, also in Nyon wird man mit Sicherheit das Ganze mit Argusaugen betrachten. Also offizielles Statement gibt es jetzt noch nicht. Aber es ist ja völlig klar, die UEFA wird nicht dulden, dass in einem ihrer Verbände solche mutmaßlichen Machenschaften, man muss ja immer noch irgendwo die Inzidenz des Promots verweiten lassen, im Konjunktiv bleiben. Klar werden die das nicht durchgehen lassen, was jetzt mögliche Sanktionen sind. Auch das wird natürlich maßgeblich davon abhängen, wie ich sage mal systemisch das Ganze am Ende aussehen wird. Wird man möglicherweise doch einzelnen Vereinen zulastlegen, gewusst zu haben oder sogar mitgemischt zu haben bei solchen Transfers, die dann am Ende am Fiskus vorbeigeschleust wurden, wo Geldwäsche im Spiel war? Also die Frage ist einfach nur, gibt es dahinter, ist der belgische Fußball krank oder sind es nur die Leute, die sich irgendwo da infiltriert haben? Das ist ein bisschen die Kernfrage. Und ich denke, das wird am Ende dann auch ausschlaggebend sein, wenn darüber diskutiert wird, ja was machen wir jetzt mit den Patienten?
Ein bisschen die FIFA-Argumentation, wo Sepp Platter natürlich auch immer sagt, dass einzelne Teile der FIFA, also einzelne Personen innerhalb der FIFA korrupt waren, aber nie die komplette Organisation war.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich dann letztlich... Es ist ja auch immer die Frage, kollektiv bestrafen, ja oder nein. Sondern jetzt irgendwo eine ganze Fußballnation, irgendwo, sag ich mal, für, ja nennen wir sie doch mal irgendwo, einzelne Kriminelle bestrafen mit dem, vielleicht mit dem Ziel, dass dann tatsächlich mal so ein Ruck durch die Fußballnation geht oder dass dann wirklich so ein heilsamer Schock damit ausgelöst wird. Ich meine, das ist ja auch mit dem Zusammenhang mit dem Hooliganismus auch immer wieder heiß diskutiert worden. Das ist eigentlich die gleiche Kernfrage dann in dem Fall.
Ja, ich könnte mir vorstellen, also nachdem das ja auch so deutlich an zwei Spielerberatern hängt und dann eben dem ehemaligen Präsidenten vom RSC Anderlecht, vielleicht ist das ja das Tröpfchen im Fass, was dazu führt, dass man den Bereich der Spielerberater international gesehen, jetzt nicht auf belgischer Ebene, sondern international gesehen, noch mal irgendwie versucht anders anzugehen. Denn wenn wir über Probleme im Fußball sprechen, die mit viel Geld, mit Korruption, mit Steuerbetrug, mit undurchsichtigem Machenschaften zu tun haben, dann hängen sehr, sehr häufig Spielerberater da mit drin.
Ja, das ist in der Tat, das hört man ja eigentlich von überall her, also diese Allmacht, die die Spielerberater aufgebaut haben, die ist erdrückend und die Vereine haben dem auch nicht viel entgegenzusetzen. Ich sag mal so Mino-Raiola oder so, das sind ja inzwischen Leute, die ja, die nicht nur Deals einfädeln, sondern letzten Endes ja einfach darüber entscheiden, ja, geht er jetzt da oder da hin? Und dementsprechend müssen die Klubs dann kuschen und so war es wie gesagt hier in Belgien auch so. Es hat sich am Ende niemand mehr getraut, irgendwo eine Moghi Bayati-Stirn zu bieten, aus Angst quasi auch über Jahre hinweg sozusagen an einer kurzen Leine gehalten zu werden, beziehungsweise dann jedes Mal bei Transfers dann in die Röhre zu schauen. Und wenn man dann auch noch einen Trainer hat, wie Heim von Haselbrook beim Erste Anderlecht, der auch ihn als Manager hat, also das ist natürlich dann, da kann man ja auch schon die Frage auf, wäre das nicht vielleicht so ein erster Schritt, dass man sagt, es muss vielleicht spezielle Makler-Manager für Trainer geben? Weil ich meine, wie ungesund ist das denn? Also im Grunde genommen würde es ja reichen, wenn Bayard seinem Van Hasenbrook sagt, hör mal, wäre nett, wenn du den Spieler holst, finde ich. Also das ist ja schon irgendwo, da sind die Interessenkonflikte ja vorprogrammiert. Und es gibt ja viele Akteure, die da eine Rolle spielen. Oder wenn es dann heißt, Spieler XY wechselt nach Bordeaux, aber sagt dann Bayard nur unter der Bedingung, dass die zu anderen auch noch mitkommen. Also da sind ja inzwischen so fast Gesetze irgendwo aktiv, die ja völlig ungesund sind. Also das geht ja wirklich zu wie auf einem türkischen Basar teilweise.
So hört es sich zumindest an. Dann gucken wir mal, ob die Justiz da eine Änderung reinbringen kann. Und was jetzt dann v.a. rauskommt, man weiß noch nicht so viel. Aber ich hoffe, wir haben jetzt das, was man sagen kann. Ganz gut erörtert, Boris. Ich danke dir sehr herzlich und bin sehr gespannt, was jetzt dann in den kommenden Tagen noch rauskommt. Und ich bin vor allem gespannt, wie viel davon dann auch noch nach Deutschland schwappt. Also ich weiß, dass du natürlich im Kicker viel darüber berichten wirst. Aber allzu viel hat man nicht davon gelesen, dafür, dass das schon eine große Nummer ist.
Dafür ist Belgien auch, muss man sagen, ja international nicht nicht bedeutend genug. Obwohl die in der UEFA-Fünfjahrswertung ist Belgien neunter. Denkt man manchmal, ja ist gar nicht so schlecht. Sie haben einen garantierten Champions-League-Gruppenphasen-Teilnehmer. Aber gut, man muss trotzdem ehrlich sagen, die Liga gilt international eben als drittklassig. Und dementsprechend ist natürlich auch das Interesse für die Liga und damit automatisch auch für einen solchen Skandal. Denn wenn das jetzt in England oder in Spanien aufgeploppt wäre heute, dann wäre natürlich was ganz anderes los gewesen, nehme ich an.
Ja, gut, das ist natürlich klar. Vielleicht habe ich da auch ein bisschen zu sehr von der belgischen Nationalmannschaft ausgedacht. Die ist halt einfach so ein bisschen der heiße Scheiß in Europa.
Ja, da gibt es auch zum Glück noch keinen Zusammenhang. Das wäre natürlich dann der Worst Case. Aber die sind da in anderen Sphären unterwegs, alle international und haben mit den offensichtlich krummen Machenschaften in der eigenen Liga nicht viel Mut, muss man sagen.
Gut, dann hoffen wir, dass das so bleibt und sind gespannt, was da noch kommt. Boris, ich danke dir sehr herzlich, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast und uns hier ein bisschen aufgeklärt hast. Add-Boris Cremer mit CREMEA heißt du bei Twitter. Da kann man dir auch sehr gerne folgen und zieht dann auch mit, was du dich sonst noch so beschäftigst, politischen Dingen. Dann vielen Dank dir, Boris, und vielen Dank euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war ein sehr spontaner Kurzpass zu einem vielleicht überraschenden Thema. Lasst gerne Feedback da, wie er euch gefallen hat, ob euch das weitergebracht hat in eurem Fußballhorizont. Und ansonsten hören wir uns wieder. Es gibt nächste Woche vermutlich zwei Tribügenspräche, und dann geht ja auch die Bundesliga zum Glück schon wieder weiter. Bis dahin wünsche ich euch eine gute Zeit. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.